[Music]
all right
the dragon gives the leopard like beast
its power
and great authority okay anthony i see
you're on
um i'll just complete the question
what are ways we see the power
seat and great authority of the beast
and we've identified this beast as the
people system
all right let me pray again father in
heaven as we continue on this most
profound subject
give us truth
clarity of expression i pray and let the
spirit of truth work on the minds of
those who are listening because the
enemy is not happy in jesus name i pray
amen
revelation 13 verses 1 and 2 and i stood
up on the sand of the sea
and saw a beast rise up out of the sea
having seven heads and ten horns and
upon his horns ten crowns and upon his
heads the names of bapsumi and the beast
which i saw was like under a leopard and
his feet was the feet of a bear and his
mouth of the mouth of the dragon
a lion and the dragon gave him his power
and his seat and great authority now
historically we trace this all the way
back to the beginnings of that was when
constantine transferred the capital of
the roman empire from rome to
constantinople in present-day turkey
that was i think around 3 30 uh beast uh
a.d when he did that this created uh
what may be regarded as a vacuum a power
vacuum in the city of rome if the
emperor is no longer seated in rome then
who symbolizes the power in and that
person rose to be the bishop of rome who
of course we call the pope the bishop of
rome now it became more formal when
justinian an emperor in 538 officially
he issued a decree called the created
the decree of justinian which made the
bishop of rome supreme above all other
bishops
and all matters concerning the church
had to be submitted to him and so in 538
the bishop of rome was officially by
decree of the emperor made the head and
he had not only religious but he also
had secular authority and so the power
which he and the seat and the authority
the power of course is the power to
carry out your decisions whatever they
are and at one point the people system
had armies that fought to subdue those
who oppose its program that's power the
authority means the legal authority to
do what needs to be done you may have
the legal authority but not the power of
the might to carry it out and of course
his throne or his seat being the seat of
rome where that's where his headquarters
was that's the seat that's his throne so
the dragon gave him his power his seat
and great authority and that system has
really had great great authority it has
risen and fallen over the hundreds of
years but it is it has been and still
continues to be a most powerful system
all gifted to the system by
the enemy power
seat by the way let me make a personal
application
the devil can give you things big things
he gave to the beast power
seat and lethargy let me say it again
the devil can give you things he can
give you high positions he can grant you
success
in quotation marks because if god
ultimately success is failure the dragon
can the devil can give you things so
don't believe because you've got so many
things you're blessed by god the devil
can give you things
it is of god when god is involved and
the glory of god is the reason for those
things but let me say again the devil
can give you things god gives us things
that may continue to grow in his grace
the devil gives us things to fatness for
the slaughter
you